for three and a half months they've been
almost inseparable in their fight for
justice but since the death of their son
Harry Dunne they'd never met the man in
charge of the investigation the 19 year
old was killed in a collision with an
sakulos
near RAF Croton in Northamptonshire she
claimed diplomatic immunity and left the
country his family were angry at what
they felt was a lack of support from the
police at the meeting they were
reassured at the end of the day there's
a resident within the county that I'm
responsible for who's died on the road
and nobody's being held accountable for
it that's not acceptable and he's not
acceptable in law that's not what I
joined the police to do and I will do
all that I can to make sure that justice
is done a few days ago and sakulos was
pictured back behind the wheel leaving
her home but has since appeared to go
back into hiding but Sky News did
approach her diplomat husband Jonathan
mr. sakulos British television will your
wife returned to the UK do you have a
message for the distraught family of
Harry Dunne it's been too much for
Harry's mum Charlotte who didn't go to
the latest meetings including a second
trip to see the foreign secretary
Dominic robbed the family had felt
misled during their last encounter I try
not to judge people too much so I think
is crossed then it will be another
productive meeting for the family after
the meeting the Foreign Office appealed
for an cyclists to come back if she's
charged
it's that support that the family have
called for four months there are darker
moments we we do wonder whether there is
a collusion between the government's and
trying to keep and cyclists back in the
United States but you know I personally
found the meeting you know quite
reassuring I feel these two meetings
today giving us hope and and I just
plead now for the CPS to please her if I
make this charge
and then we can move on the Foreign
Office paid tribute to the tenacity of
Harry's family and friends in their
determination to get justice they say
their fight will continue for as long as
it takes
Lisa Dowd sky news